[Music]  yesterday dr. Phil we all know dr. Phil  he interviewed Donald Sterling's  assistant V stiviano and he really  grilled her about all the rumors that  she was actually Sterling's mistress now  I know he's a doctor but I don't think  all of dr. Phil's questions were  entirely appropriate take a look I have  never had any sexual relationship with  mr. sterling the day I attended his  office for my first interview and  thereafter until today you did not have  sexual interaction with him the day you  visited his office no he says that you  went into a private area where sexual  favors were performed absolutely you've  never had sex with him define sex any  type of sexual contact you define sex  type of sexual fondling no nudity no no  never no  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  see look his mine I think he lifted that  technique from Barbara Walters all right  she's retired now what could she do to  me  good move Andy now's the time to strike